[dubstep]
WOO!
Damn it feels good to be on top!
Anotha day, still kickin' it!
Tch!
It's been quite the uh-- eventful week, to say the least.
*laughs*
So much has happened.
So why not let's just JUMP into it, guys?
And review this week's LWIAY?
"When you make a meme all by yourself."
"But you divide it to give some karma to your friend too"
*laughing*
Is it two different people? It is.
*clapping*
Bravo. Well done.
This is 2 days ago, "The gap has shrunk to 15k."
WELL NOT ANYMORE!
HA HA!
It really looked like it was the end, didn't it?
Me, Joel, and Dave recorded a video
for 16 hours straight just to make sure that it'd go out in time
but now it looks like we have literally like weeks!
*laughs*
Oh well. Not complaining.
"74 MILLION--"
*laughing*
This is so ridiculous!
How?
Welcome all new subscribers!
We post memes here, by the way. If you expected anything else, I don't know what to tell you.
Literally millions of new subscribers.
I hope you enjoy the memes that we post on this channel.
It's literally every single day. Thank you very much.
What an absolute legend! "Someone hacked printers worldwide, urging people to subscribe to PewDiePie."
I'll have you know, my mom thought this was hilarious.
So thank you again, HackerGiraffe.
"DILLION the Hacker."
*laughs*
"Put nothing at the end of your videos."
"Put ASS at the end of your videos."
"Put ads at the end of your videos."
"Put a clip from Marzia's channel at the end, and then have Marzia claim the video"
"before anyone else to guarantee that you get the revenue from your video."
Oh my...[Ayumu Kasuga voice] GAAAAAH!!
You know YouTube has a broken system when ironic memes is actually facts.
*laughs*
When idiotic ideas as a meme is an actual good idea.
That's how you know you have a broken system, YouTube.
"Playing Bih Lasagna for 10 hours to save PewDiePie vs T-Series."
Davie504. He also made another video where he played Bih Lasagna on a lasagna
Then again you could also play Bih Lasagna on an actual lasagna.
That's the real reason-- *laughs*
That's the real way to do it.
"Recently a lot of Indian YouTubers, who have significant audience have started making videos against PewDiePie."
"Many are of the impression that he is desperate in defeating T-Series and he actually disrespected the whole country of India."
"Many of them are saying he is hiding behind sarcasm and memes to show his hate."
"I as an Indian 9-year-old understand this is not true. But most of them doesn't. So maybe Pewds please address this fact."
"They are making it INDIA vs West thing. Pewds tell everyone it's not like that. And yes, T-Series is indeed--" *laughing*
You almost had a nice message there until the very end.
I saw this post and I seen a lot of people addressing it.
and that's part of the reason why I wanted to do the charity campaign that we did.
So, I appreciate that you guys raised these concerns to me as well
and uh, I hope we can make a change.
And I hope-- I think we have now already.
We raised, in total, $253k towards CRY to help children in India.
Thank you again. So much. To everyone that showed up on the livestream and everyone that donated.
10k people. Over 10k people donated and chipped in.
Thank you all, so much.
And everyone that just came to to show your support as well.
Amazing. So proud. Honestly. Could not be more proud of this audience right now.
"Shout out to Notch and Markiplier for their 10k donations."
Thank you both very much. Very cool.
"What's up 9-year-olds, a few months ago I found this channel on the subreddit because some tried to get him on LWIAY."
"His name is Steven, he made drawings every day while he was in the hospital. Sadly he had cancer, and even worse it got the best of him."
"As a final goodbye to Steven, Subscribe."
Steven: "Ay yo guys it's Theweevster18 and I'm just telling you guys I'm not gonna be here forever."
"'Cause of the tumor I have. It's gonna make me die and sorry if I'm crying a little bit."
"When times come, the YouTube channel can still be growing. You guys should be hitting the like button and all."
"Remember I'll always be in your guys' hearts. But it's gonna be ok. So I'll see you guys. Remember to hit the like button."
"Subscribe. And hit the bell for notifications. And I'll see you guys in the next vid. Peace out."
"Hi everyone. It's Papa Weev and Mama Weev here."
"You haven't heard from us in awhile or Steven actually, I'm sorry."
"Um. Unfortunately he passed away on Nov. 28th."
"About a week ago or so."
"And my wife and I just want to tell you that we're all so happy that you all have been supportive for Steven."
"And we just want to tell you that we're gonna continue the channel."
"We're so happy that the support that came through for Steven you know, before he died"
"he told us that he wanted us to continue the channel..."
I'm gonna leave Steven's channel in the description. Go ahead and show your support.
And also, they have a Make-A-Wish fundraiser as well for Steven in his name.
So I'll link to that as well if you wanna check that out and maybe donate as well.
Damn. That got real.
Back to memes!
Ok. Alright.
Mr. Beast, "Guys, the battle with T-Series is getting intense and casualties are high."
"Should we call Logan and Jake Paul for help? Is winning worth sacrificing everything?"
Yes? Ok. Alright.
I wonder if Logan Paul would do it. I wonder.
Could we put our differences aside. Come on Logan! What's it gonna be?
That's right, I'm that desperate.
*laughs*
I'll take any help I can get.
The king. The king's right hand. The last hope.
The general. The infiltrator. The sage. The virgin.
Ohh that's great.
"Thank you Pewds."
"He protec, he attac, but most importantly..."
"He helps kids in India get bac on trac."
*laughing*
*clapping*
This. Is so. Wholesome.
Can we smash thousand subscribers?
"This subscribe to PewDiePie blah blah blah and blah and honestly I don't feel like I deserve it."
*laughs*
Thank you for the caption there by the way, very nice.
"That is why it must be you!"
*laughing*
"Ok this is epic. Johnny Dee did his part by singing Bih Lasagna."
Johnny Dee! The sage of the PewDiePie channel!
[Johnny Dee singing to Bih Lasagna]
Thank you as always, Johnny Dee. You're an absolute legend.
"Boogie2988 did his part. 'Youtube is about the individuals not the corporations.'"
"Francis Eats Only Salad til PewDiePie Beats T-Series"
WHY DID I NOT SEE THAT?
Did he actually do that?
*laughing*
Thank you, Boogie.
"Is this a supermarket?"
"No, it's over there."
"k. thx."
*laughs*
WHY IS THIS MEME still going?
"Pewd's shopping adventure."
That actually sounds like a good game.
What do I collect? Demonetization? Come on, get out of here.
Oh--wait, he's actually making a game! Are you kidding me?
"I'm making a game for Pewds, please up-vote this so he can see it and give me permission to put it on the Play Store."
Well I mean, we split the revenue. Obviously. 👀
*laughs*
"Markiplier finally doing his part."
*kiss*
Thank you Markiplier.
VERY cool.
"This is what we're doing bois no excuses."
"If YouTube Rewind doesn't start with Pewds clapping 'year review' we all hit dislike button."
👏 👏
SPOILERS. It's not gonna happen.
And double spoilers, please don't do that. Don't hate on the video just 'cause I'm not in it.
It's just childish and stupid, there's no reason for it."
"Pete is joining us."
"And there I am with no legs."
"Tell PewDiePie he's not the only one."
*laughs*
Is he playing Roblox?
"Things that disappear when you need them the most."
Keys! Wallet! Phone! Marki--
WELL. Not anymore!
NOT ANYMORE!
"These three little words are a big turn-on."
"Subscribe to PewDiePie."
That kinda looks like JackScepticEye, doesn't it?
"I got married last week, we don't like you T-Series."
Are you serious?
[Bih Lasagna playing]
*laughing*
[Bih Lasagna Playing]
*laughing and clapping*
That's amazing!
Yeah? What happened there?! I don't know!
I got a bunch of Tweets that I lost like 20k and T-Series gained 50k?
What the frick?!
"Secnd try getting this into LWIAY, I worked pretty hard on it but nobody wiill give a shit. Also they did surgery on a grape."
Well not I'm definitely not showing it.
Ok, fine! What is it?
Kowalski!
Analysis!
Put fitting--
*laughs*
Woah!
OH!
It's amazing!
Absolutely incredible. We're adding this to ASS right away!
"Dear 9-year-olds: Are we actually going to make a new account for tomorrow to sub to Pewds?"
I dunno if you can actually do that. I mean it's not like I tried or anything...
But uh, I think now you need a cell phone number to create another account.
So basically what I'm telling you is to steal phones.
That was a joke. Moving on!
Ha. Ha ha ha.
"PewDiePie raising millions of dollars for charity."
"Media:"
Ha ha ha
I know that's like supposed to be a meme, ahem...
But literally the same day that uh--
Oh yeah, Telegraph's, same day. Same day as the live stream.
"When fans go too far: 'Stan stunts', and YouTube's next big problem."
So ridiculous!
[Pew News Theme]
So they tried to make the whole hacker thing seem like a negative-- seem like a DANGEROUS thing
we're literally out here-- you know what. This is not even worth time.
[Pew News Theme]
Anyway, uh. "5 mil on YouTube in 6 months, never done before--" Ok.
This meme is just growing more and more.
*laughing*
It would be funny if we could hit 5 million on YouTube in 6...uh 6...what would it be?
6 weeks?
We've definitely done that I think.
"Ok what we really need is for Shane Dawson to make an 8 part documentary on PewDiePie."
"The dark side--"ah ok. Thank you Grandayy. Thank you.
"When you wake up and see that the difference of subs went from 10k to 300k+"
Ah!!
*laughs*
Seriously me too. We were so panicking.
"CONFIRMED: PewDiePie is in Fortnite. This is his last chance to beat T-Series."
Wow! That actually looks pretty cool.
*laughing* Who did this?
Samarskiy. Thank you Epic Games. VERY cool.
"Buying PewDiePie a $1M Billboard in Times Square."
"A surprise to be sure, but a welcome one."
Does it really cost 1 million though?
I mean I appreciate it regardless but, that cannot have cost 1 million.
"Hit or miss. I guess they never missed, huh?"
"Got a boyfriend? I bet he doesn't kiss ya!"
"Ughh!!"
"By the Nine! He hit the dab!"
*laughing*
Oh that's brilliant!
God dammit, I love TikTok now.
That's right. I'm saying it. TikTok is epic!
"Rare pic of men discovering fire."
[nose scratching sounds]
Are you saying Bih Lasagna is fire? Because you're GODDAMN RIGHT it is.
"When you spend a million but only get 100k views. Poor lad."
Is that true?
Oh. This is so sad.
"We're in the endgame now."
Nope! Season 2 just started.
*laughing*
Trust me guys. There's a lot of stuff.
I've been saving the best bits. I'm not saying anything more than that.
But there's some stuff that uh, we're only getting started, ok.
"I asked Tommy Wiseau if he supports PewDiePie in this war against T-Series and he responded..."
"Do you remember the YouTuber PewDiePie who made the video about you awhile back, and you followed him on Twitter?"
Tommy: "Ok. Well, what's your question?"
"My question is that..."
Tommy: "Beautiful background, by the way. You give us really nice feedback here."
"Thank you!"
"Um, he is currently losing the war up against T-Series in term of subscribers. He has 72 million, they have 72 million."
"And it's a really tight race, and I think it'd be a big help if you could support this man who supported you."
Tommy: "Yeah I support him to the rest of my life. Good luck to him..."
*cheering and laughing*
*Felix laughing*
Thank you Tommy Wiseau! I support you for the rest of my life as well.
God damn. What a beautiful man.
"Why did PewDiePie create Ethan Klein--?"
People kept saying it! Now I see it!
I'm sorry, come on. Ethan is way cuter. Come on.
"PewDiePie vs. T-Series can't be described better."
*laughing*
Pretty much it.
I really appreciate the white font over the white background.
Really good meme!
Like this is all it takes to get on LWIAY guys.
*laughing*
"Doing my part in Israel. Printed a big magnet for my car-- for my work car for Pewds."
Thank you very much Israel, VERY cool.
"Petition for 257 to host Meme Review."
*laughing*
That would be cool! Honestly. Maybe I'll try and track him down.
That'd be awesome.
"In 60 years: I didn't fought for any World Wars but I fought in something more important."
"Grandson: What was it?"
You know, I was a 9-year-old as well once.
*laughing*
"Gonna prank Pewds when I finally surpass him."
👏 👏
YES! IT'S NEVER HAPPENING T-SERIES! GET IT IN YOUR BRAINS!
That's it for this week's LWIAY!
I cannot thank you enough, everyone.
Everyone! I have an announcement to make.
BUY THE MERCH!
Last chaaaance!!
Epic merch!
I'm buying 15!